les discussions avec monsieur rail
combas ce sens verrait tout à fait
constructive est dans une atmosphère de
confiance nous avons à bordeaux n'est
abordé lors relations multilatérales est
nos relations bilatérales et la
situation au niveau de l'onu et de
l'europe et la visite de monsieur heiko
maas à la veille de l'aisne les 50 ans
de la signature de l'accord qui avait
été signé pour consolider les efforts de
paix en europe et l'original de cet ce
traité a été exposé dans cette salle et
le 12 août 1960 disent les signataires
avaient apprécié justement le caractère
selon lui pacifique et qui était un
choix stratégique en faveur d'un respect
mutuel entre nous les pays occidentaux
et le ss et c'était la volonté du
chancelier willy brandt qui à l'époque
qui était favorable au maintien de la
paix et de la normalisation des
relations en europe
ce traité consolide l idée de
coexistence pacifique sur le continent
européen et il a contribué à la tenue de
réunions de discussion qui se sont
conclus par l'acte final de d'helsinki
sur le désarmement entre l'urss et
notamment la rfa les enfants des
relations sur le plan économique
scientifique d'enseignement touristiques
etc tout cela
et les travaux concrets qui ont été
faits dans le domaine des échanges au
niveau pour les années croisées et tout
cela nous mène à la prochaine année
croisée qui aura lieu entre le deux pays
dans le domaine économique et commercial
et donc nous lançons l'année de
l'allemagne en russie cette année et je
pense que compte tenu des données liées
à kona virus nous pourrons organiser une
cérémonie six sur la place de smolensk à
moscou et en même temps nous avons
apprécié les salutations sera dressé par
le gouvernement allemand à l'occasion
des célébrations en l'honneur de du
blocus de leningrad et aujourd'hui
monsieur heiko maas va rencontrer des
anciens combattants des personnes qui
ont vécu le blocus de leningrad
nous avons mis l'accent sur l'achèvement
du chantier de l'ensm de contenu de la
pressions considérables exercées par les
etats-unis dans le cadre de ce projet
nous avons encore rappelé notre position
de principe qui est le soutien à ce
projet qui vise à assurer la diversité
des idées
aux fournitures d'audace pour l'europe
plus que c'est l'europe elle-même qui a
besoin de cette diversité de
fournisseurs et nous avons exprimé à la
partie allant de notre préoccupation
dans en matière de cybersécurité dans
nos relations bilatérales puisque
l'année dernière et cette année nous
avons noté un certain nombre de d'attac
de cyberattaques provenant d'allemagne
contre des organisations russes
nous avons aussi parlé de la question
ukrainienne nous sommes bien d'accord
sur le fait qu'il n'y a pas
d'alternative aux accords de minsk et
nous avons appelé encore une fois nos
collègues allemands à exercer une
influence sur les autorités de kiev pour
qu'elles de prennent leurs
responsabilités en matière de respect
des obligations contractées à minsk et
nous avons encore insisté sur le fait
que le format normandie sur la question
iranienne est un format de discussions
normales qui doit permettre de résoudre
directement les problèmes sur le terrain
dans le respect des accords de beats
encore une fois le respect le strict
respect de la résolution 22 54 du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu sur la
syrie confirme là l'importance du
respect de
l'intégrité territoriale et de
l'indépendance du pays
et encore une fois cela doit permettre
une reprise des travaux du comité
constitutionnel à genève et nous
accordons une grande importance à la
mise en place de mesures d'ordre
humanitaire pour alléger les souffrances
de la population syrienne
nous avons aussi un intérêt commun
concernant la libye et nous confiant bon
la communautéde approche entre la russie
l'allemagne sur la nécessité de trouver
une solution politique au conflit en
libye et ce qui avait été dont c'est
déjà lors de la conférence de berlin et
dans le respect de la charte de l'onu
nous paraît encore une fois nécessaire
de respecter toutes les décisions
adoptées lors de la rencontre de berlin
parce que la reprise le regain des
tensions sur le terrain ne fait que
présenter
de plus en plus de menace pour la paix
dans ce pays et nous devons conjuguer
nos efforts pour assurer le la
restitution le retour de l'état et
l'intégrité territoriale du pays en
conformité avec la résolution du conseil
de sécurité de l'onu qui a été adoptée
et nous avons parlé aussi de l'accord
sur le nucléaire iranien
et encore une fois ici une idée qui est
promue par nos collègues européens et la
russie haussier à faire certain nombre
de propositions
tout cela devrait permettre de reprendre
la coopération de tous sans exception de
tous ceux toutes les parties qui ont été
si des terres de cet accord sur le
nucléaire iranien
nous allons discuter de ces initiatives
et nous allons également coopérer sur un
certain nombre d'autres orientations
dans le haut niveau de l'eau et sur les
différentes plateformes
je vous exprime ma reconnaissance à
monsieur heiko maas d'avoir décidé de
venir ici à moscou mais ton corps en
place notre calendrier de coopération je
vous remercie
poser des problèmes dans notre
coopération il ya des questions
compliquées mais nous avons toujours été
en contact nous avons été nuls des
conférences nous avons eu des entretiens
téléphoniques mais quand même il ya des
sujets qui exigeait une discussion en
personne
nous avons aujourd'hui vu le traité de
moscou qui a été une étape importante de
la politique visant à réduire les
tensions et qui a permis de développer
les relations pacifiques entre nos deux
pays à l'époque actuelle il est
nécessaire de se souvenir de ces accords
de ces événements en pleine guerre
froide et willy brandt avec sa politique
a réussi à réduire les tensions ce qui a
permis de développer les relations entre
nos pays a une grande importance pour
l'avenir de l'europe
c'était une nouvelle orientation et qui
a un permis plus tard de d'assurer la
réunion des deux qui alerta et
l'allemagne de l'est
nous constatons actuellement qu'il ya
plusieurs initiatives for my dialogue
par exemple là le dialogue de
saint-pétersbourg qui
trente ans c'est aussi dans le cadre de
jalozai croisé il ya beaucoup
d'évènements qui ont été prévues fin mai
n'ont pas été organisées à cause du
courant d'un virus mais nous allons
faire en sorte qu'on puisse se rétablir
en aux échanges au niveau politique
ainsi que dans le domaine économique
culturelle à d'autres domaines nous
pouvons pas les slaves qui ne peut pas
gagner une relation à cause de problèmes
pratiques ou d'autres problèmes il faut
parler franchement et ouvertement ce que
nous avons toujours fait par le passé et
l'assassinât en allemagne qui selon le
parquet fédéral a été commanditée par la
russie a posé des problèmes pour une
relation et je dois souligner que la
sécurité en allemagne y compris la cyber
sécurité doit être assurée sans aucun
compromis et sub discussions contribuer
au développement des relations pour
éviter les problèmes paraît dans nos
relations il ya de nombreux sujets où
elle est nécessaire de retrouver les
solutions ensemble voudrions discuter de
l'ensemble de problèmes et notamment
aujourd'hui après ses conférences de
presse nous allons poursuivre nos
échanges et c'est une relation
bilatérale ainsi que de la l'ordre du
jour international dans le cadre des
organisations internationales par
exemple au sein des nations unies
il ya aussi une possibilité de
coopération mais il ya de bons
changements les décisions du sommet
précédent sur ma normandie
ces décisions nous doivent rester sur
papier mais il faut prendre des mesures
pour cela l'équipe réunissons une
nécessaire les compromis de la part de
toutes les parties
il ya des progrès par exemple concernant
le seul feu et il nous allons poursuivre
de travailler dans ce format pour que
les décisions prises soient mises en
oeuvre et tout ce que tout le monde
contribue alors mise à mes bras quand le
cessez-le-feu c'est un symbole positif
j'en ai déjà parlé mais il faut
respecter le cessez-le-feu
parce que le cessez-le-feu a été annoncé
à mon entreprise et nous sommes contents
que cela a permis à la population qui
est déjà fatigué la population sur le
terrain de faire une pause nous allons
parler de la situation au moyen-orient
les parties au conflit libyen
aqua toujours avec le vrai nom c'est à
des compromis complexe et à l'aide
extérieure
exerçaient leur pression sur une autre
partie mais ce n'est pas acceptable et
nous allons soutenir les nations unies
dans ce domaine la situation devient aux
enjeux complexes
ceux qui essaient de d'agir d'une
manière unilatérale ne veulent pas
trouver une solution et nous avons
toujours évité cdh approche unilatérale
et dans le cadre du processus de berlin
en coopération avec le conseil sécurité
de l'onu
l'allemagne va jouer un rôle principal
ceux qui consomment 1 concerne le
contrôle des armements la russie et les
etats unis jouent le rôle clé une
responsabilité particulière en ce qui
concerne le traité sur la non
prolifération et le renforcement de ce
régime il est nécessaire d'essayer de
prolonger le traité new star le traité
start parce que cela nous permettra
d'inviter la chine a participé à ce
travail ce qui est nécessaire est très
important dans le contexte du régime du
contrôle des armements pour que les
tendances
al'inverse ne deviennent pas plus forte
après cette réunion
je pars pour son petit retour où je vais
accorder une attention particulière à un
des moments les plus sombres de notre
histoire commune le siège de leningrad
c'est un crime terrible et l'allemagne
responsable pour ce crime
nous ne devons pas l'oublier à l'année
passée
nous sommes convenus que l'allemagne
allait se tenir les ceux qui ont survécu
à la siège de la rade un soutenons
l'hôpital pour les anciens combattants à
leningrad
je voudrais vous remercier de votre
soutien merci aussi à 24 bonjour tout
cela vole tout d'abord au nom des
journalistes russes je voudrais vous
remercier d'avoir contrôlé la situation
avec les journalistes et russes en
biélorussie mais quand même deux
journalistes sont toujours injoignable à
un violeur russie je sais que vous avez
tenu des négociations avec leurs
homologues via la rue c'est qu'ils sont
quels sont les résultats de ces
négociations
et est-ce que vous avez parlé de ce
sujet avec heiko maas et la seconde
question sur le cren dans le contexte de
cette crise
on parle beaucoup du roi la doller ce
elle selon vous est ce que les
observateurs de l'osce se remplit
peuvent remplir leurs tâches
actuellement
merci bien entendu nous nous intéressons
à la question qui concerne la situation
des journalistes qui sont de concitoyens
hier l'ambassadeur de fédération de
russie et d'autres départements de la
presse et de l'information ont discuté
avec le cynisme accueille et nous sommes
toujours préoccupés par la question de
la libération de ses journalistes nous
comprenons bien que
nombre de nos journalistes parmi ceux
qui ont été arrêtés n'avait pas
d'accréditation
il n'avait pas toujours respecté les
procédures mais ici dans cette situation
rider il est important d'adopter une
attitude positive sur le plan humain
donc aujourd'hui nous avons eu de
nouveau des informations sur le fait que
nous n'avons pas de contact avec vos
collègues mais notamment un représentant
du journaliste de mendoza pas seulement
comme journaliste d'un média russe mais
aussi comme concitoyens russe et donc ça
fait plus l'objet de nos discussions
avec nos homologues bien malheureusement
quand il ya des émeutes des désordres
sur la voie publique
comme nous l'avons vu dans d'autres pays
par exemple en europe en france avec les
gilets jaunes et donc quand il ya des
journalistes qui cherchent à donner une
couverture objective des événements
ils sont souvent victimes eux-mêmes de
violence mais c'était le cas aussi d'une
représentante de rt mais c'est donc de
contacts bilatéraux à tous les niveaux
avec nos partenaires nous cherchons à
éviter toute mesure de discrimination et
nous cherchons il faut bien comprendre
que chacun doit respecter les procédures
la législation du pays dans lequel ils
opèrent
mais ceci dit doit y avoir une approche
qui doit être la même pour tous les
journalistes
donc il peut y avoir des médias qui sont
qui font de la propagande et qui ne
reflète pas toujours
l'objectif de leur travail de
journaliste c'est pas parce que cela se
passe aujourd'hui on ira aussi mais
parce que c'est toujours le cas dans
toutes les situations on a des désordres
sur la voie publique et on l'a vu dans
le cas des gilets jaunes et encore
récemment en allemagne ou 2017 par
exemple les antimondialistes
à hambourg lors du g20 on a vu on a vu
ce qui s'était passé
donc encore une fois nous n'avons pas
parlé du la biélorussie mais je pense
que à l'occasion de notre repas nous
allons parler à propos de le crâne oui
nous avons parlé nous travaillons
étroitement avec l'allemagne dans le
cadre du format normandie et on ce qui
concerne la mission de surveillance de
leur soeur
nous soutenons ce mécanisme qui a un
mandat particulier tout à fait précis
sur le territoire ne le craignent pas
seul mort dont le nom de bath mais aussi
dans d'autres régions et craignait en
matière de suivi du respect des droits
de l'homme notamment on voit un certain
nombre de menaces dans le pays mais nous
nous étions donc l'attention de des
responsables de l'ouest sur cette
question l'aspect de l'activité qui est
menée et des observations de la
communauté internationale sur le respect
des accords de minsk tout cela ce site
tournoi s'attendre de questions nous
paraît important par exemple de signaler
les infractions au cessez-le-feu
donc on a souvent des chiffres abstraits
cependant un certain nombre de jours il
ya eu tant de nos fraction donc un
certain 2
de d'infrastructures civiles ont été
visées un certain nombre de personnes
ont souffert mais ce n'est pas la
première fois que nous demandons à ce
que la mission donne des informations
plus concrètes plus précise à l'aide à
l'aide de notre représentation presque
sur la base des rapports quotidiens
chaotique a convaincu mener un travail
d'analysé précis détaillé j'appartiens
de ce qui a été publié dans le domaine
public et on a vu que plus de 80% des
bombardement de sites civils proviennent
des troupes ukrainienne la majorité des
civils qui ont souffert ce saut ce sont
principalement des gens qui sont du côté
des séparatistes donc on a la preuve que
ce sont nés
les forces armées ukrainiennes qui sont
le plus coupable des infractions cessez
le feu
donc le respect des obligations du
traité 2000 ça fait partie justement que
l'armée ukrainienne respecte je voulais
le cessez-le-feu est ce qu'on voudrait
c'est que les rapports de l'eau ce choix
précis qui disent qui est auteurs des
infractions au cessez-le-feu qui est
victime
pourquoi des civils meurent donc c'est
situation dans ces bombardements veut
donc des informations qu'ils soient plus
précises donc nous demandons au centre
de respect cessation des conflits et
leur donner des indications précises et
ça fait partie de leur responsabilité
personnelle c'est-à-dire cette volonté
de dissimuler des informations et de ne
pas suivre le respect total des
obligations d accorder mon collègue dans
son mode entre de son a évoqué le sommet
de paris et encore une fois il était
question il avait été question à paris
justement d'une stricte au respect des
accords de mythe et je suis bien
d'accord que il faut des avancées de
tout les côtés des deux côtés des trois
côtés mais encore une fois
j'attire l'attention de nos collègues
français et allemand ce du format
nordique
il y à un certain nombre de déclarations
qui ont été faites à kiev et notamment
le vice premier ministre qui représente
qui est fait dans une des structures de
combattre qui déclare que les accords de
mines ce que sont devenus désuets et il
disait que voudrait qu'il voudrait une
explication deux explications sur ses
désaccords mais encore une fois l'ancien
président ukrainien kraft chaude déclaré
qu' il regrettait que le président
céline ce qui est signé cette
déclaration d'autres il ya beaucoup de
choses assez curieuse ici et encore une
fois il faut encourager les efforts qui
positive qui ont été faits sur le
terrain mais il y a des accords très
clair qui ont été signés et il faut pas
s'arrêter
justement il faut pas que ce soit
l'arbre qui cache la forêt c'est à dire
que ces détails positif ne chache ne
cache pas le l'importance du statut des
accords de nuit et j'espère que deux
homologues français et allemand au sort
ont résonné les autorités de kiev en
matière de respect des accords de minsk
je vous remercie quand tu es un
quant à la biélorussie je voudrais
souligner encore une fois que estimant
que ceux qui sont descendus dans la rue
pour manifester de manière pacifique
doivent être libérés immédiatement et
notamment les journalistes qui font leur
travail
et on entacher ce journaliste de travail
et doivent être libérés immédiatement
parce que la liberté de la presse
ça c'est une partie de la démocratie
libérale qui existe en allemagne est
malheureusement on constate que le
travail journalistes non seulement en
biélorussie mais partout où il y à des
conflits est limité et parfois même
interdit et il y a des conséquences
négatives pour les journalistes
la communauté internationale doit se
poser décisivement à ce phénomène je
vous rappelle que l'union européenne ce
qui concerne en biélorussie et les
événements récents à l'union européenne
à lever les sanctions contre la
biélorussie parce que ce pays a pris les
mesures nécessaires pense par exemple à
libérer les prisonniers en question mais
face aux récents événements que nous
avons vu ces derniers jours je ne sais
pas si cette décision sera peut-être
modifier en ce qui concerne le cren nous
nous avons une base très clair pour
notre travail c'est la décision sont les
décisions du sommet en format normandie
qui a eu lieu en décembre dernier à
paris je vous rappelle que la russie a
soutenu c'est
la décision est par exemple le feu et
après de nombreuses discussions la mise
en oeuvre des décisions du sommet de
paris et est un signal très important
mais d'autres actions sont nécessaires
par exemple la solution des questions
humanitaires et d'autres questions
nous nous estimons que ce très bien que
la mission d'observation à continue de
d'exercer leur travail ce qui était
difficile pendant la pandémie mais
maintenant la situation à améliorer en
ce qui concerne les violations dieu
cessez-le-feu qu'on constate
malheureusement ici nous devons créer
des structures pour inquiéter sur ces
violations parce que les deux parties
affirme toujours que c'est l'autre
partie qui a violé le cessez-le-feu et
s'il y avait une structure compétente
cela aurait été plus facile de vérifier
qui est coupable mais quelle fischer
dégâts monsieur le ministre monsieur
lavrov vous avez dit que les états unis
renforçaient leur menace contre le nord
stream 2 après la situation en allemagne
on voit qu'il appelle à des mesures de
rétorsion monsieur masse est ce que vous
croyez que
la ligne rouge a été déjà franchi est ce
que vous avez des mesures à proposer et
monsieur lavrov est ce que vous attendez
des mesures de la part de l'allemagne
et je voudrais poser une question à vous
deux
est ce que vous pouvez imaginer contenu
des ralentissements dans la construction
du pipeline est ce que la construction
peut être terminé jusqu'à la fin de
l'année pour nous pour le gouvernement
allemand les liens transatlantiques
actuellement et depuis deux décennies
ont une importance particulière non
seulement pour nous mais pour l'europe
en général ce sont les liens qui sont
plus profonds que les intérêts
conjoncturels politique mais on de
constater que les sanctions entre les
partenaires
c'est dans mauvais goût c'est une
mauvaise voie c'est notre solution
souveraine nous acheter les les
ressources énergétiques et personne ne
peut imposer à l'union européenne leur
volonté on parle de ces sanctions et on
va discuter de ce sujet avec nos
partenaires pour établir si ces
sanctions sont conformes au droit
international aux noms et g
merci je crois que la question s'adresse
ainsi à moi je suis d'accord avec ce que
ce que dirait commencent les sanctions
extraterritoriale par principe comme
sanctions unilatérales qui sont promus
premier nom passe non seulement par les
jeunes aussi parler nos repères
notamment contrairement aux états unis
l'union européenne s'abstient de
d'appliquer le caractère
extraterritorial mais encore une fois il
s'agit ici sans aucune sous un quart
cours à la diplomatie il s'agit
simplement d'imposer sa volonté et ce
qui permet aux américains de faire ce
kil de ce qu'ils leur ce qu'ils
entendent là et quand ils le veulent
dawes le retrait total de la plupart des
traités internationaux des organisations
internationales et des structures qui
peuvent être considéré comme dissuasif
et comme des sources de retenue et donc
malgré tout nous poursuivons nos
contacts avec les états unis c'est le
pragmatisme qui l'imposent
mais nous voyons très bien la façon le
comportement de mme washington sur la
red internationale qui se comportent
absolument sans gêne sur tous les
théâtres et les etats unis ont
clairement annoncé qu'ils allaient un
terreau faire capoter le projet de nord
stream 2 parce que les états unis sont
préoccupés de l'indépendance énergétique
de l'europe d'alors s'ils sont prêts
assurer la sécurité de l'europe la
sécurité énergétique de leur âge et à ce
moment là s'il impose des sanctions aux
sociétés qui travaillent dans le projet
north aux 2 et à ce moment là si
washington a envie de discuter à ce
moment là c'est son choix mais encore
une fois la république fédérale
d'allemagne à sa position et elle
soutient sa position elle a raison je
chante en ce que ce qui est dit à
washington plus haut niveau quand on dit
que les états unis assure l'indépendance
de l'allemagne et l'allemagne paie des
milliards à la russie mais c'est une
déformation des faits encore une fois
pour voit que l'alliance nord atlantique
est importante pour la sécurité de
l'allemagne
mais madame merkel récemment a encore
déclaré que l'otan est une garantie mais
la question que nous posons nous c'est
c'est une protection contre quoi nous
n'avons pas reçu de réponse mais une
partie de cette discussion qui porte sur
les principes qui établissent notre
dialogue
encore une fois il s'agit de la sécurité
dans la région euro atlantique
encore une fois ici les entreprises
concernées participantes au programme
nordstrom 2 que ce soit les sauveteurs
russes ou ou européennes sont bien
d'accord sur le fait que ce projet doit
être achevée mener jusqu'au bout et nous
espérons et nous avons toutes les
raisons de croire que cela sera fait
très prochainement
merci j'ai une question à monsieur match
c'est sur le même sujet nord stream
quelles mesures le gouvernement allemand
peut-il prendre afin de d'aider les
sociétés allemand un protégé ce projet
parce que là on a déjà eu la même
situation avec le pipeline orengo et
uche gorod les états unis ont passé les
sanctions contre ce gazoduc
mais les pays européens ont réagi et ont
aidé à sauver ce projet est une autre
question mais sur lavrov selon vous il
ya eu des attaques contre les objets
d'infrastructures russes en provenance
de l'allemagne
pourriez vous en parler plus en détail
et igor match le premier ministre
slovaque vient de dire que la slovaquie
et la russie sont des amis mais à la
slovaquie cet ampli ce ver ans et on ne
peut pas se moquer des règles
diplomatiques
qu'est ce que vous pouvez dire à ce
sujet des sanctions imposées par
washington
j'ai déjà tout dit pour nous c'est un
sujet important c'est un des sujets qui
est au coeur de notre présidence l
allemagne actuellement le pays qui
préside l'union européenne et le sujet
de la souveraineté de l'union européenne
pour mu est un sujet important face à la
concurrence entre les grandes puissances
non
voulons avoir un choc de confiance
nous avons les mêmes valeurs au centre
de l'union européenne et nous avons
certains intérêts et si quelqu'un essaie
de dean aurait nos intérêts nous devons
réagir
et s'il s'agit des situations comme par
exemple l'assassinât à berlin où les
attaques contre les attaques des hackers
contrôler le bundestag bien sûr ce sont
aussi les situations préoccupantes
l'europe doit faire plus pour assurer sa
sécurité et protéger ses intérêts ses
valeurs et que par le passé l'europe ne
peut le faire que si tous les pays sur
ellis et nous voulons que l'union
européenne
respecte ses valeurs et ses intérêts
quand j'entends ensemble parce que cela
nous permettra d'avoir des positions
claires en ce qui concerne la cyber
sécurité et les questions informatiques
qui lient à en russie un centre de
coordination nationale sur les incidents
de nature cyber et nous travaillons avec
un certain nombre de partenaires et
notamment en allemagne et ce centre
russe ce centre de coordination veut sur
les incidents informatiques
depuis janvier les navires jusqu'à fin
mai de cette année à noter si ma mémoire
est bonne 75 cas de ressources russes
dont plus de 50 qui sont publiques qui
ont été victimes d' attaque de cyber
attaques depuis le segment allemande
internet
donc nous avons adressé des avis à la
structure équivalente
en allemagne et nous n'avons reçu de
réponse que pour sept d'entre eux et
c'était des réponses tout à fait formels
officielle qui sur le fond ne répondez
pas à la question
donc nous demandons à ce qu'une enquête
professionnelle sur chacun de ces cas et
notamment quand il s'agit de ressources
internet qui dépendent de l'état et donc
on a aujourd'hui une préoccupation et
nous avons fait part de notre de cette
préoccupation puisque nous demandons que
ces problèmes soient résolus et
notamment que cette
ce mépris dans lequel sont tenus nous
demande c'est savait que nous ayons une
réponse est que ça fait partie des
relations d'amitié entre la russie et
l'allemagne
donc vous voyez cette statistique dont
ce que je viens d'évoquer
aujourd'hui nous avons aussi des
consultations en matière de
cybersécurité au sein d'une commission
spécialisée entre nos deux pays sur le
plan militaire sur le plan civil et en
une de ces consultations justement à
l'initiative allemagne da hd cet
événement était justement pour
simplifier ces démarches
aujourd'hui quand nous avons parlé de
l'activité du groupe de travail de haut
niveau en matière de sécurité
donc il ya un groupe de travail qui
existe dans ce domaine entre nos deux
pays et nous avons juste mot abordé
l'éventualité de création de re création
d'un tel organe qui puisse agir dans le
domaine de la cyber sécurité qui
permettent de passer de la parole aux
actes et de travailler 2 face aux
problématiques liste ensuite concert de
l'assassinât qui a été commis à
thiergarten à berlin la vérité a été
établi l'eau services ont transmis aux
services russes aux services allemands
tout ce qui était demandé
nous aussi nous aimerions avoir une
confirmation une preuve et
puisque le procureur général d'allemagne
avait déclaré qu' il avait déclaré que
l'état russe était directement lié à ce
meurtre
or nous n'avons pour l'instant reçu
aucune réponse concrète et précise sur
la slovaquie oui ce qui concerne le fait
que la slovaquie est un pays ami avec la
russie et jeu tout à fait d'accord nous
avons jamais eu de problèmes politiques
sur le jeu penche le problème ici n'est
pas dans la slovaquie elle même jeu et a
eu cette phrase qui était prononcé de la
souveraineté de la slovaquie tous
d'accoucher chez lui aujourd'hui
représentant officiel du département
d'état américain madaba ces gosses à a
apprécié cette décision des autorités
slovaques de d'expulser trois diplomates
us à part à paroles autour du aucun
commentaire dans la presse étrangère
donc je pense que peut-être que ça
signifie que certains aux etats-unis
sont intéressés à ce que la slovaquie
prenne de telles mesures
j'ai une question à monsieur masse vous
avez souligné que pour une relation il
est important de discuter des questions
préoccupantes comme par exemple
l'assassinât tiers cartels ou l'attaqué
quand le bundestag selon vous est ce que
ces discussions vaart ont donné des
résultats quels sont les résultats
est ce qu'il y a
des signal qui montre et que la russie
est prête à contribuer à l'enquêté de
ses affaires quelles sont les
conséquences possibles pour les
relations entre l'allemagne et la revue
ce monsieur lavrov
est ce que vous partagez la vie de votre
homologue et que c'est bon de discuter
de ces questions comme l'assassinât
tiergarten est ce que c'est bon d'en
discuter fortement et est ce que vous
pourriez de donner vos commentaires sur
une autre affaire
lee à la russie est ce que vous pouvez
confirmer que vers carte que l'ancien
président de vannes carte
monsieur marc chollet keita lasne ou en
allemagne merci je je voudrais commencer
tu as donné un commentaire sur ces
affaires qui ont compliqué nos relations
ces dernières mois en ce qui concerne
l'assassinât des regards de la situation
est comme suit le tribunal s'occupe de
cette affaire et c'est le tribunal qui
prendra la décision et le gouvernement
allemand va attendre la décision puisse
par le tribunal
une autre réaction suivra après cette
décision
si le procureur général constate que
l'assassinât qui ce qu qui a eu lieu en
plein jour en allemagne qui est le
procurant générale constate que cet
assassinat a été commanditée par notre
pays
ça doit à un incident qui doivent faire
l'objet de l'enquète ça doit être une
enquête approfondie
c'est très important pour nous que le
passé nous avons essayé à maintes
reprises d'obtenir des informations de
la part des ministères et agences russes
nous avons envoyé les cette demande au
service pénale services de protection de
la constitution et cetera mais nous à
nous n'avons reçu aucune réponse
nous avons demandé de l'aide légale mais
nous avons reçu une réponse uniquement
moitié de nos questions donc nous avons
fait tout notre possible maintenant
c'est le tribunal qui doit agir
le tribunal doit prendre sa décision et
cela servira pour nous de base pour à
réagir si le tribunal constate la
coupable était ou la non culpabilité
nous allons réagir de la même manière en
ce qui concerne les attaques les
cyberattaques
nous n'avons parlé aujourd'hui ici nous
avons des évaluations différentes
il ya des reproches mutuels et les deux
parties c'est de les éviter de clarifier
la situation de voir s'il y a des les
vraies raisons
nous envoyons nos demandes et parfois il
ya des réponses qui permet de préciser
la situation parfois non mais il est
nécessaire d'utiliser les canaux qui
existe entre non spécialistes une
mystère et j'estime que
les opportunités qui existent grâce
notre équipe r espace ne doivent pas
être utilisés pour avoir des conflits
dans sécuriser l'espace et nous nous
basons sur ce principe s'il ya des
attaques dans mci leur espace nous
allons inquiétèrent sur cet incident et
essayer d'établir et qui est responsable
pour ces attaques donc des échanges sont
nécessaires dans ce domaine pour éviter
de telles situations
à propos de monsieur marc schleck je
suis pas au courant aussi se trouve en
allemagne la question de ne me concerne
pas et je suis peu informés des
activités déplacement de ce monsieur
en ce qui concerne la discussion de
façon publique qu'il s'agisse de
tiergarten ou autre nous sommes toujours
prêts ce n'est pas par notre initiative
qui à un certain nombre de canaux de
conversations ont été fermés notamment
du côté allemand depuis 2014
ça a été l'initiative de l'union
européenne à plusieurs reprises nous
considérons cela de façon philosophique
si nos partenaires sont prêts à discuter
nous y sommes prêts mais contiennent
quand ils auront la volonté de réviser
leur politique à l'égard de la russie
nous nous serons prêts à discuter de
façon ouverte et franche sur toutes les
questions qu'ils présenteront d'intérêt
commun d'autant plus que ces questions
sont nombreuses mais encore une fois je
tiens à le souligner mais correa le
procureur général allemand qui dit que
l'état russe est lié au meurtre de
thierry hartl nous aimerions avoir une
preuve pour l'instant nous n'avons
aucune comme l'a dit aïe combat sur un
certain nombre de demandes nous avons
répondu aux questions qui nous ont été
adressées new services compétents et je
le répète encore une fois le canal de
dialogue en particulier sur la cyber
sécurité
si on se souvient de l'année 2015 et un
certain nombre des accusations contre la
russie
selon lesquelles elle aurait attaqué le
bundestag mais je tiens à vous rappeler
que puisque la question posée et
j'espère vous avez entendu ma réponse à
la question précédente
l'organisme de
conversation entre les deux pays avaient
été fermées par l'albanie les deux os et
aujourd'hui nous sommes intéressés à
rouvrir ce dialogue sous une forme ou
une autre et si il y à cette opportunité
cet intérêt à ce moment là d'autant plus
que nous avons aussi à sa forme de
questions à aborder notamment les 75 de
mode que nous avons adressé à la partie
allemande puisqu'il y avait donc 75
cyber agression de la part du secteur
allemand d'internet à l'égard de la
russie donc je suis content
qu'aujourd'hui nous puissions parler
nous sommes de façon ouverte sur ces
questions qui présentent un grand
intérêt mais aussi parce que enfin nous
comprenons la nécessité de recourir au
processus de discussions entre
professionnels qu'il s'agisse de
questions politiques ou pas politique
tout simplement parce que avec
l'allemagne nous sommes des partenaires
nous sommes de bons amis et ne voudrions
pas que cette coopération souffre 2
quelques péripéties que ce que ce soit
en tout cas nous la russie nous sommes
toujours prêts à discuter je vous
remercie